et dans la lignée de ce que vient de
dire le premier ministre croit que nous
partageons tous ici bien entendu ce
socle de la république la liberté
d'expression étant ce pilier fondamental
pour notre république notre démocratie
je dirais de façon plus générale la
démocratie dans le monde
j'en profite pour dire qu'il ya un
immense élan de solidarité
internationale que je vois au travers
des ministres de l'éducation du monde
entier vous poser une question très
concrète et je vais vous répondre
répondre très concrètement
d'abord samedi dernier avec le premier
ministre nous avons reçu les
organisations syndicales et ensuite j'ai
reçu les organisations représentant des
parents d'élèves
j'ai été n'ont pas frappé parce que je
m'y attendais mais en tout cas très
heureux de voir que nous avions cette
unité si indispensable cette convergence
de vues sur les valeurs de la république
et cette demande des organisations
syndicales que pour le jour de la
rentrée le 2 novembre mais aussi pour
les temps après suivant nous ayons une
des consignes claires nettes précises et
forte sur ce qui va se passer
c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé au conseil
des sages de la laïcité que j'ai créée
il ya trois ans précisément pour créer
ce système de référence dont nous avons
besoin et qu'ils existent je lui a
demandé de siéger en permanence pour
recevoir l'ensemble des organisations
des élus qui souhaitent être écouté en
ce moment pour faire des propositions
aussi bien sur cette rentrée que sur la
suite y compris en matière de protection
des professeurs et donc d'ici quelques
jours je donnerais évidemment ces
consignes claires nettes et précises sur
le déroulé du 2 d'ores et déjà je vous
en dis une qui vous concerne directement
c'est que je demande à tous les élus de
la république et conseillers municipaux
les maires vous même bien entendu
l'ensemble dès élus de la république
d'être présent auprès des professeurs le
jour de cette rentrée ça me paraît très
important il ya d'autres mesures qui
seront prises
j'aurai l'occasion peut-être d'en
reparler aujourd'hui même je vous
remercie